RICK: What do we have here?
I have an antique clock.
It's been my family for
about four generations.
It's brass.
It's an antique carriage clock.
RICK: OK.
Cool.
This carriage clock
design came along,
I think, right around 1800ish--
somewhere around there.
And they were sort of
like a fashion thing,
which I don't understand at all.
My kids tell me
this all the time.
Constantly, I'm walking out
the house, and my daughters go,
you're really gonna wear that?
[laughs]
JEANNE: The clock has been
stowed away for a long time.
And I discovered it
recently after we were
cleaning my mom's apartment.
I'm looking for
$1,500. $1,500 will
buy a lot of really fun shoes.
RICK: It's really, really cool.
This carriage clock
design-- it was basically
designed to be a travel clock.
You just couldn't
jump on the plane
and go to New York
for the weekend.
That's right.
RICK: You were gone for months.
And rich people brought
tons of baggage with them.
So why not bring a
clock with you, too?
So, you know,
carriage clocks were
originally portable clocks.
But the portable clocks, they
still made sort of like this.
This looks 1900ish to me
just the way the design is
and the way the movement is.
Does it run?
JEANNE: I'm not actually sure.
I do have the original winder.
RICK: It's called the key.
The key.
RICK: OK.
Well, we'll find out real quick.
That's scary.
I just wound it and saw
that this was already wound.
It's broken.
OK.
So did you have an idea
of what you wanted for it?
JEANNE: Well, I was
originally thinking $1,500.
I think it's kind of cool that
it's got the original case
and the original key.
RICK: It's great
history and everything,
but even if it was running, this
thing's worth maybe $100-$150.
OK.
RICK: It'd cost me
more to fix this
than what I can sell it for.
JEANNE: I understand.
So there's no offer?
No offer.
But thanks for bringing it in.
It's really cool.
And it's a great
conversation piece.
JEANNE: Of course.
RICK: OK.
Have a good one.
- Thanks.
You too.
I feel a little
disappointed that there's
no interest in the clock.
I'm going to take the clock home
and display it on our mantle
proudly.